Android instant apps make it possible
for users to access you app without
having to install it first
imagine users opening your app just by
clicking on a link in an email or a text
message we've recently made android
instant apps available to all Android
developers to take full advantage of
this we have some best practices to help
you make your intern apps user
experience as great as that in your
installed app or maybe even better you
can find all this and more at the URL in
description below it's important to keep
in mind that by enabling your app to run
instantly without installation you're
not creating another additional app
we're thinking of in synapse is another
way to use the app your users already
know and love it's the same app just
without installation by adding the
ability to access your app directly from
a link a search results or another app
it's much easier for users to engage
with your app and get excited about it
if they decide to keep your app on their
device permanently they can then install
it right from within the instant app the
ability to launch an app without having
to install it provides an enormous
opportunity for a long time app
developers have focused on the number of
app installations as a proxy for the
metrics their business really cares
about without installation users simply
weren't able to engage with the
developers offerings at all removing
this barrier to entry and enables you to
think about the metrics your business
really cares about your audience is now
just one tap away from engaging with
your service your instant app is just
another mode your app can run in so
don't branch your UI and make any
unnecessary unnecessary changes
regarding the layout interface design or
experience of your incident the
transition from instant to install mode
after installation should be a smooth
and seamless as possible your users
should have a rich and cool app
experience even if they haven't
installed your app rather than thinking
of instant apps as a limiting factor to
what your audience can do think of it as
an opportunity to get them to your
functionality quicker and a way to
foster your relationship with them avoid
prompting your users to install the app
when they're in the middle of a task
that will be much more inclined to place
your app onto their
permanently after it has had the
opportunity to prove its usefulness
refrain from bouncing them back and
forth between your instant app and your
mobile web offerings you can probably
tell by now
instant apps are all about removing
frictions for your users in getting them
closer to your functionality think about
ways you can remove further barriers for
your users for example wait until users
can see the benefit of making an account
and signing in until the value of doing
so becomes apparent asking users to
create an account after installation
seems like a small additional ask when
they've already gone through the app
installation flow and are only just
getting started however when they're
coming from a link looking for specific
content or functionality being asked to
register can feel very disruptive
additionally make sure to use available
API to make your and your users life
easier using Google's smart lock for
example make signing up and signing in a
much simpler and straightforward
experience in summary we really think
that instan apps will unlock a lot of
opportunity to engage your audience more
directly users will be able to focus on
what it is they want to accomplish
rather than having to spend time
maintaining and updating apps on their
phone we're super excited to see what
you come up with everything I talked
about here and much more you can find on
jidoka
slash in synapse thanks for watching
[Music]